el presidente de azerbaiyán ilham alíyev
decretó este lunes una movilización
parcial en el país debido a la escalada
de las tensiones en el enclave de
nagorno karabaj el domingo el líder
decretó también la ley marcial en todo
el país y un toque de queda en algunas
ciudades al intervenir ante el consejo
de seguridad del país el mandatario
prometió no ceder ni un ápice en el
conflicto con armenia azerbaiyán
azerbaiyán no llevó a cabo ninguna
provocación azerbayán está simplemente
defendiendo sus intereses apoyando su
posición y siguiendo abiertamente su
política hemos declarado repetidamente
que nagorno karabaj es la principal
patria histórica de azerbayán y en
cierto
sí ambos bandos se culpan mutuamente por
agresiones
los dirigentes del autoproclamado
independiente de nagorno karabaj dieron
un paso más adelante este lunes hablando
de la participación activa de otra
potencia de la región
quiero declarar que no solo azerbaiyán
sino también turquía está en guerra con
nosotros están usando las principales
armas y municiones modernas disponibles
en el ejército turco drones y aviones
en ereván apoyo mayor de nagorno karabaj
se reunieron centenares de civiles
dispuestos a dar una mano a su ejército
en las pocas horas que lleva el
conflicto ya son decenas las víctimas
fatales de ambos bandos a principios de
los años 90 el enclave fue escenario de
una guerra en la que murieron 30.000
personas desde entonces las autoridades
azerbaiyanas han tratado de recuperar el
control de la misma aunque se acordó una
pase en 1994 la querella territorial
siempre causó inestabilidad en la región